mirabel une immense circonscription où
se côtoient agriculteurs et travailleurs
de l'aérospatiale la banlieue y est en
pleine expansion
ici les électeurs vivent au quotidien
les problèmes de circulation
c'est ce développement déjà après à des
services qui vont avec les développeurs
pour certains la campagne électorale
prend une tournure qui s'éloigne des
réelles préoccupations
moi je pense qu'on devrait se concentrer
plus ce raid est votre société réelle
plutôt que de parler d'un élément
vestimentaire qui touchent moins d'un
pour cent dans % de la population
pour l'instant on parle pas des enjeux
de société la politique en laisse
d'autres complètement indifférent moi je
vote même pas pour de vrai j'ai jamais
voté pourquoi je pense pas que mon
opinion à compte vraiment
c'est l'heure du midi au salon qui de
saint janvier ici pas de doute tout le
monde va aller voter le 19 octobre
mais pour ce groupe de retraités faire
un x dans le prochain caro est bien plus
important que de discuter politique
fédérale je vous revois tes parents
depuis lors de voter pour voter mais sam
hamad série d'élections maintenant entre
deux lancers ce qu'ils disent c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas l'impression d'être
écoutés par les politiciens
si la date des élections approche
plusieurs n'ont pas encore fait leur
choix
non j'ai pas d'idée aucune idée encore
c'est vous qui a beaucoup de monde comme
bouquet qui qu'hésitant taghmaoui même
cette souverainiste convaincu hésite on
est bien embêté pour voter alors parce
qu'on veut pas ça veut pas que c'est un
grand club avec si on vote pour le bloc
mes enfants m'ont dit vous faut voter
comme acquise et ce donc votre
stratégique tac l'aï dit il par le jump
et des plats la dernière mon fils m'a
dit j'ai nullement votre talent ont
aussi pu non la région longtemps dominé
par le bloc est passé au npd en 2011
cette fois malgré une très longue
campagne ils sont nombreux à ne rien dit
si ici vincent maisonneuve radio-canada
mirabel